as the nation's vaccine drive ramps up
dollar
general has become one of the first
large companies to offer employees
an incentive to get shots the retailer
said it will give hourly employees an
extra
four hours of pay if they get vaccinated
dollar general employs more than 157 000
people
across 46 states many of them have been
working inside stores
during the pandemic linkedin polled its
users
to see if they think employees should
make vaccinations mandatory
46 percent say yes 40 say no 14
are unsure jesse hempel is linked in
senior editor-at-large jesse good
morning
thanks for being with us good morning do
you think other companies are going to
follow
a dollar general's lead on this i think
there's no question that we're going to
see companies start to speak up
and talk about the incentives that
they're going to use to try to encourage
their employees to get vaccinated
absolutely what what do you think um
what's the debate inside corporations at
this point because there's the issue of
do you make it mandatory because you
want everybody in your workforce
to be safe what are they talking about
i think that you've actually hit on the
tension here i mean there is pressure to
make it mandatory
certainly i was surprised that so many
members of linkedin's community thought
that it was a good idea nearly half of
the people who weighed in
said yes do make it mandatory but of
course companies know that if they make
it mandatory which
they can legally do they risk alienating
and further polarizing their employees
and so the balance here is to provide
the incentives that are
going to encourage them to do the right
thing in the name of science for public
health
while also allowing them to feel that
they are making the decision
what responsibilities do do corporations
and companies businesses have
to help their employees get vaccinated
at this point
well businesses are in such a unique
position right now because they really
are leaders in culture and society and
so their responsibilities are definitely
to their employees but when dollar
general makes a statement like they made
yesterday
it's reported on national news here we
are talking about it on television
because it also sends a really
important message to society to their
employee base but also their customer
base
and the communities in which they do
business in so many ways companies are
actually have been leading during this
in terms of encouraging you know stores
telling people you got to wear a mask
which governments aren't doing i think
about that all the time because
if you look at what trust has done in
our society over the last couple of
decades you've seen trust plummet in
institutions like
the media like government and yet people
trust businesses more and more and more
they're looking to businesses
rightly or wrongly for messages about
how they should behave and how they
should treat each other
and so businesses have a unique
opportunity right now to step up
and be leaders here but it's also in
their interest is it not if you want
your workforce back
uh and in many cases they need to be
back and to be safe
oh no question no question um business
as usual is not going to happen until
people are
vaccinated until people are through this
pandemic and that is not going to happen
until we get that vaccination rolled out
as quickly as possible and i so wish
that it would be happening more quickly
but the truth is it's going to be a long
time from here this is going to be a
slow process
even when we do start to go back to our
offices we're going to be using
the kind of protocols with social
distance and masks that um that we see
today
you mentioned that there is this
conversation going about on about
whether to make it mandatory or not and
and that incentives is a better idea but
but obviously
businesses are going to want to move
quickly on this once things
start to turn so so what's the
conversation then
you know what's the friction in the
conversation then at this moment
i think that what i'm seeing in
conversations on linkedin is
um questions about the vaccine we know a
lot about the vaccine we know the
vaccine protects you we want to know
more about what the vaccine does for the
community of people
in the office as you know it is
unresolved yet whether or not
research doesn't tell us whether you can
still pass covet even if you don't get
covid
um so i think that businesses are going
to need to wait to let some of that
be um further understood before they
bring people back on mass
and i think also what i'm seeing in
conversations on linkedin
is that um people by and large even
though they don't want their employees
to mandate this
they're really asking for their
employees to encourage this people are
not going to feel safe at least they're
telling us that on linkedin
until they feel like most of the people
in fact all of the people that they're
going to work with have gotten the
vaccine
jesse ample of linkedin thank you so
much for being with us this morning
thank you